welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
vos and spider-man far from home screen
an exclusive extended edition featuring
several deleted scenes that were removed
from the film I guess that's what a
deleted scene is I gotta say Sony picked
a hell of a week to ask diehard Marvel
fans for more money but hey this is also
probably our last chance to see an MCU
Peter Parker on the big screen for a
while at least until Disney egos
everything into its monopolistic blob so
I'm gonna quickly break down this new
footage that was included in the
extended cut and how it changed the
overall experience of the movie boiler
warning if you haven't seen far from
home yet / if you just don't want to
know this stuff and yeah I'm on a
different set because we are actually
currently moving and it's actually gonna
help us bring some new exciting stuff to
you guys and for the first time ever I
got to taste that sweet sweet flavor of
real fresh air outside of the blue
dungeon that I had been locked in okay
as you may already know the deleted
scenes showed the removed New York
montage that the filmmaking team
mentioned shortly after the film came
out so while the movie's theatrical cut
jumps straight from Peter and Ned
strategizing their m.j plan in the
classroom to Aunt May's charity event
the extended cut shows all the stuff in
between the errands that Peter Parker
has to do before he leaves we actually
saw some of this in trailers - the movie
it includes Peter going to the post
office to get his passport we see him
using a robotic spider to sneak over
crawl under the closed window flip the
switch
so that it's open so that he won't have
to wait in a long line Peter also
reunites with mr. del Mar in the bodega
for the first movie he's picking up some
toiletries our european wall outlet
adapter and he tries to order a dual
headphone adapter and broken spanish
that mr. del mar calls him out on
there's also another scene that we knew
about in which Peter trades in a bunch
of his action figures at a pawn shop
including some he-man ones and at the
last second he says actually can I keep
the Lobot Lobot is the guy from Star
Wars Episode five the Empire Strikes
Back
Lando Calrissian right-hand man I did a
whole other video about what the scene
would be and then there's the other
trailer sequence in which Peter beats up
a bunch of members of the Manfredi crime
family in a restaurant
the man Freddy's are a reference to
Silvio Manfredi one of the lesser known
Spidey villains Silvermane I always
loved showing that guy in a video so all
the action here is really well
choreographed and with the iron spider
armor in this street-level scenario
peter is pretty much a god mode the only
thing I wasn't crazy about was the
dialogue like Peter makes a bunch of
corny one-liners alright I'm gonna give
this place 1 star fresh ground pepper
that's it I'm definitely not gonna give
you a 20% tip and yeah these are exactly
the kind of jokes Peter Parker has
always made but they just don't come
with that pathetic self awareness that
this MCU spider-man has always had like
this Peter's jokes don't always land or
if they do land it immediately follows
with him getting knocked on his ass I do
understand wanting to see Peter Parker's
iron spider suit in action in his
everyday crime-fighting as opposed to
you know like fighting apocalyptic
threats over and over again a nerdy kid
like him probably would want to take
this out for a few spins but I also
understand why the filmmakers cut the
sequence like it's just a bit odd for
Peter to be immediately joyriding in
this armor while we are still feeling a
bit depressed over Tony Stark's death so
really it makes more sense to jump ahead
to the scene in which Peter is forced to
reflect on its relationship with his old
papa stark and overall we don't need to
spend this much time in New York when
the main narrative a far from home takes
Peter far from home where he runs into
Mysterio in Nick Fury and by the way
during this rewatch you start to notice
all kinds of hidden sightings of Quentin
Beck and his whole team like not just
that early Gyllenhaal cameo that we
spotted right after the movie came out
but a number of others on the team who
bumped shoulders with Peter including
gute ermine it's actually kind of creepy
how intensely these adults were stalking
Peter throughout Venice and one more
detail that's worth noting in this
deleted footage before Peter runs his
errands there's a shot of him walking
and talking with Ned in his high school
hallway as all the other students are
celebrating this last day of school and
there's a shot of Flash Thompson empty
in his locker dumping a bunch of
crumbled garbage into the bin and then
he turns to get Peter and Ned the
dullest or saddest look as they pass him
maybe flash is just reacting blankly to
hearing Peter talk about getting his
passport and digging himself huh wait my
passport says I'm five years older than
I am maybe I'll be able to drink on the
airplane or this could be the first of
many sad cries for help for Flash
Thompson throughout part from home
parents who won't return his texts or at
the end of the film will pick him up
from the airport and now we get to see
Flash threw away a metaphor for his
crumbled soul so why do we get these
lonely little flash flashes I have
offered a number of theories for what
this could mean for the third spider-man
film like a Flash Thompson venom
connection maybe his mother works for
the light foundation or maybe Flash
Thompson goes on to play some kind of
Harry Osborn type role or maybe it's
just that Flash's loneliness could end
up bringing him closer with Peter in
this next spider-man film and which it
looks like Peter will become a pariah
and would need to lean on some friend
who was
previously a known associate or you know
flash is just a major a-hole and far
from home loves to remind us of his
hollow-core every moment it can would
you have preferred if these scenes were
left in far from home
comment down below with your thoughts
follow me on his sir command twitter at
EA vas and subscribed into rockstars
some more breakdowns of everything
Marvel thank you for joining me and you
know if Sony really wanted Vance back in
the theater to rewatch far from home
they could just make like an extended
edition that's really just like a whole
nother film of Spider Man still in the
MCU and just a suggestion
[Music]